many Disney Villains seem to meet
gruesome ends in their movies but that's
not necessarily the end of the story for
all of them some might very well still
be alive keep watching to discover which
fate was dreamt up for one villain only
to be used a few years later for another
if it finds even the slightest ray of
sunshine it destroys it
Maleficent in the 1959 movie Sleeping
Beauty the assumption is that Prince
Philip defeats Maleficent in her dragon
form after all he throws the Sword of
Truth into her belly and she falls off a
cliff they like to jack up a minute and
really examine the evidence
when Philip looks over the cliff edge
all he sees is the sword embedded in
what appears to be Maleficent's shredded
cloak there's no sign of Maleficent so
perhaps she got away because let's get
real Maleficent is one seriously
powerful bad fairy when she faces off
against Philip she tells him he'll have
to deal with her and all the powers of
hell that's full-on Wright's
sure the three good fairies magically
empowered the Sword of Truth before
Philip thrusted at Maleficent but we
know their magic isn't as powerful as
Maleficent after all they couldn't
straight up remove her curse at Aurora's
christening Disney has even shown how
Maleficent could live on after the
events of Sleeping Beauty in the
anthology Disney's scary story buck
collection there's a tale called
Maleficent's revenge two years after the
events of the film Diablo the Raven
comes back to life he finds Maleficent's
cloak and staff and uses the evil
fairies magic to revive her she has
another fight in dragon form with Philip
but this time she causes her own end by
accidentally biting her own tail with
her venomous fangs
however she revived once so she could do
so again the Evil Queen the fact that
Maleficent is alive and kicking in The
Descendants movies suggests that she
certainly does have the ability to
reanimate and she's not the only villain
living on the Isle of the Lost the Evil
Queen from Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs is also a resident there and like
Maleficent her suppose at end in the
original 1937 movie is pretty ambiguous
to the dwarfs chase her to a rocky cliff
edge trapped at the top the Evil Queen
tries to lever a giant boulder to roll
down onto the dwarfs but instead
of crushing them with it the bolder plan
backfires a bolt of lightning strikes
the edge of the cliff sending her over
the edge
the dwarfs gaze over the edge as the two
vultures ominously swooped down to get
their fill however we don't actually see
her body for all we know she managed to
escape she has strong powers after all
like dark magic and witchcraft in The
Descendants movies we see her alive and
well and living on the Isle of the lost
and she still has some of her magic
mirror so perhaps her magic powers saved
her all of this is sounding very
familiar right falling off a cliff no
evidence of the remains it's just like
Maleficent and these two have another
villainous accomplice in descendants who
is still alive Jafar at the end of the
1992 movie Aladdin the villain Jafar is
locked up as a genie in a lamp and
thrown far far away the intention is for
him to stay imprisoned in his lamp in
the Cave of Wonders bickering with his
parrot Iago for no less than 10,000
years sure that's not the end of him and
an ultimate sense but if you look into
Jafar spate after that it gets really
interesting in the sequel the return of
Jafar we seemingly witnessed Jafar as
ultimate end Iago eventually turns
against his former master and kicks
Jafar's lamp into a lava lake we watch
as the lamp melts and Jafar is
electrocuted before imploding into a
cloud of dust and sparks that seems like
a pretty definite end
but does this really destroy him for
good oh no it doesn't the god of the
underworld Hades later revives Jafar in
an episode of the Hercules animated
series TV spinoff thanks to Hades
enchanting to forest snake staff Jafar
transforms into a living man again he
has sorcerer powers and is essentially
immortal as long as he has his staff
however Aladdin Hercules defeat Jafar in
the underworld after Hercules breaks to
fara staff the villain gets sealed in
the river Styx
but given that he's come back to life
before it's easy to see how Jafar could
still be alive and he is on the Isle of
the Lost
in descendants as Jays dad Ursula Ursula
is another villain that is alive and
kicking in The Descendants franchise
second movie Ursula makes a cameo
appearance she owns Ursula's fish and
chips on the Isle of the loss and we see
her slapped one of her arms on the
pirate gang ordering them to be quiet
and washed the dishes but what about her
original fate it would seem that Ursula
was defeated once and for all when Eric
ship impaled her body in the 1989 movie
The Little Mermaid to add insult to the
injury there was also a lightning strike
that electrocuted her body but we
mustn't forget that the sea which is
part activist and if we look into the
powers of a real octopus we discover
that Ursula's fate might not be that
cut-and-dry these amazing creatures can
regenerate limbs and tissue when
something is severed they also have
three hearts
so perhaps Ursula was able to regenerate
underwater and live on shan-yu in the
1998 movie Mulan shan-yu seems to
succumb to a spectacular demise when
Mulan battles him on the Emperor's
Palace rooftop after Mulan pins him to
the roof with his own sword Mu Shu
launches a rocket at him the villain is
then propelled into a tower full of
fireworks we assume he meets his fate in
the explosion but we don't actually see
this occur and there's an intriguing
reason why he might have survived sure
he has superhuman strength and endurance
but he also has a spiritual element too
there's a deleted scene where Shan Yu
watches the action through the eyes of
his Falcon the director Tony Bancroft
explained they had the idea of Shan Yu
being a spiritual character that could
see through the Falcons eyes however
they scrapped the idea as they needed to
focus on developing the character of
Mulan instead perhaps Shan Yu was able
to use Falcon power to escape the
explosion dragon drag gun not lizard I
don't do that tongue thing Lucifer
lady tremaine scat in the 1950 movie
Cinderella
appears to meet his end when Bruno the
dog chases him out of the window many
viewers assume that Lucifer's fate is
sealed however in the movie itself we
don't actually see what happens to him
after he shoots out the window as we all
know cats typically land on their feet
and there's a saying that cats have nine
lives so we've also seen what's called
an uncut version of the scene on the
internet that shows Lucifer actually
falling and spotted on the ground and it
leaves us with no and
Beauty as to what happened to the cat
however many fans don't consider this to
be a genuine Disney deleted scene and
there's no evidence elsewhere that this
happened regardless of that Lucifer does
certainly live on in the
straight-to-video sequels in the second
movie called dreams come true we see
Lucifer fall in love with a snobby
palace cat called pom pom in the third
movie at twists and thyme Lucifer is
still owned by the wicked stepmother
Lady Germain reverses time with the
fairy godmothers wand and turns Lucifer
into a human coachman dr. facile ear dr.
facile ears end in the 2009 movie the
princess in the frog is a more unusual
demise compared to many other villains
when Tiana in frog form destroys facile
ears talisman his friends from the other
side arrived to take him away they
intend to collect the Shadowman soul as
he's failed to repay his debt we see his
shadow and him being dragged into their
spirit realm through the Voodoo mask as
they vanished they leave behind only a
tombstone with facile ears name and face
engraved onto it although this seems to
confirm the witch doctors death it's not
necessarily the end as we've seen with
Jafar spirits can be revived to become
living people in the other realms and we
do see fasoli are alive and well in
another Kingdom
faseler exists in the descendants world
although he's not seen in the first two
movies instead he's a character in the
prequel novel called Isle of the Lost
he's the headmaster of the island school
dragon hall there he attempts to teach
the younger generation how to take over
the world when their powers get restored
we also see his daughter
Freddie Faso the air and the animated
short from series descendants wicked
world so he certainly lives on Mother
Gothel
Mother Gothel also speech 'red and the
descendants prequel novel she's one of
the villains brought to life on the Isle
of the Lost in that world she has a
daughter called Ginny Gothel and she
teaches selfishness 101 at dragon Hall
school of course in the 2010 movie
Tangled we see mother Gothel fall from
the tower to her end
however unlike many other villains that
are seemingly destroyed by a fall that's
not the case for Gotham it seems like it
was extreme old age that caused her
demise by the time she reaches the
ground her cloak is actually almost
empty and when it makes contact with the
grass a small puff of dust is all that's
left now most of us would assume
that was the end of her after all when
Flynn cut Rapunzel's hair with the shard
of glass from the broken mirror it
destroyed the power of her hair and that
results in Mother Gothel rapidly aging
in front of our very eyes her skin
wrinkles and her hair turns white but
none of us actually know what would
happen in this kind of situation would
her body really wither away entirely or
might Shiva scaped somehow Gaston most
Beauty and the Beast fans probably
assumed that Gaston got his due at the
end of the 1991 animated movie after all
we see him plummet from the top of
beasts castle after he loses his footing
on the rain-soaked balcony edge
eagle-eyed viewers will have even seen
skulls flash in Gaston's eyes as he
falls hundreds of feet down
however like Maleficent and the Evil
Queen before him we never actually see
gasps Dawn's body and the massive ravine
he's heading towards has water flowing
through it show us unlikely that anyone
would survive that but it's not
impossible as we've seen in Mulan too
Shang Falls from a great height into a
water ravine and everyone assumes the
worst but he survives and much is made
of Gaston strength in Beauty and the
Beast so if anyone can beat the odds its
him even the actor who provided Gaston
boys Richard white believes Gaston
survived white reckons Gaston merely got
a nasty bump after his bad fall there
was also a different version of gasps
Stan's demise in an earlier script but
that was used for a different villain in
the end scar scar also meets his
apparent fate by falling off the cliff
and The Lion King
it's fascinating to discover that scars
scene was inspired by a rejected option
for gasps Stan's end in one of the
earliest scripts Gaston and beasts were
made to battle in a forest Belle would
strike Gaston from behind with a rock
causing him to fall off a cliff although
Gaston would survive the fall he would
then see the Wolves that attacks Maurice
and Belle earlier and they would delve
into him however the idea was rejected
because the writers thought it was too
gruesome but they obviously didn't want
to scrap the idea altogether as a
slightly altered version popped up a few
years later in the 1994 movie The Lion
King
only with hyenas instead of wolves Simba
hurls scar off the edge of Pride Rock
and then the bitter hyenas go in on him
however we only see them leap on him in
the shadows created by the fire sure it
does look like it's curtains for scar
if the hyenas didn't finish him off then
the fire probably would have there was
an alternate ending for scar 2 which
involved him being consumed by flames
but Disney ultimately rejected it as I
thought it was too graphic that's pretty
ironic given that they eventually chose
an ending that they thought was too
scary to use for gustin's demise so
that's a wrap on 10 Disney villains who
could still be alive
who do you think survived their parents
end and which is your favorite of all
the Disney villains be sure to let us
know in the comments thanks for watching
make sure to subscribe to the things for
more videos like this one we'll see you
next time
[Music]